và đoàn trọng khi phòng trang hà mắt đã phần gánh đọc thái này.
Giờ qua sát nhận định lệnh bắt,
chỉ mà tính biểu được,
giò thủ những kỳ không có thâm quyền thích thí bên ngoài lạnh thổ.
Đồng thạch của ISTAN Bồn cũng dễ ra khi cung ngày 13 thăm em một
hạng thục tần rời tờ dẫn các ngon tiền tình bảo miễn cho thấy
các cố vấn pháp li của quân độ Israent tình cạnh bảo nội mộ rằng
một số hát đầu quân sự đại giải gà ra có thể vi phạm tội A trên Trang
nhưng chỉ quyền của tổng thống cho vài đình phía đó đã không kết lợi Israent B phạm được pháp của tế
để có thể tiếp tục vệnh cho thật của quân i tế dạ gà ra
hơn số mấy đáng yên tạm trong người palestín là thịt mạng trong 2 năm xung đô
chủ yếu là dẫn thường.